it looks like painting in the sky except
with hardened steel a new technology
developed by Dutch startup MX 3d is set
to revolutionize the world of 3d
printing it enables the construction of
highly complex structures made of metal
in unprecedented dimensions we use
robots in a way nobody's using them in
the car industry and in almost all
industry people spend engineers spend a
lot of time programming the robot it
spend like months programming the robot
to do one thing repetitively what we do
is more generative so that means we have
to shoot new information in the robot
all the time so every piece of
information of the robot printing is
completely different from the last one
the concept centers on a robotic arm
that can be rotated along six different
planes of movement there's a printhead
that works in a style similar to that of
a blowtorch reaching temperatures of up
to 1500 degrees Celsius it can mold
metal into all manner of objects both
vertically and horizontally
you can use it for different industrial
applications friends with everything you
build out of steel if you have to
produce one of the kind parts it's
really complex and really expensive you
have to make molds for every piece you
make you have to make a mold and we can
just print basically almost any shape we
want and among the more challenging
shapes abridge the team has designed
this structure to spend one of the 200
canals found in Amsterdam what sets this
bridge apart from the 1200 already
gracing their home city is that it will
be printed on insight from embankment to
embankment
we're not stuck to a bounding box
anymore because we use a robot we can
move out of the bounding box and print
from existing structure it's really
interesting 3d printing and architecture
is also being explored at the Swiss
Federal Institute of Technology its use
here is more subtle with a computer
turning artificial sandstone and two
elements you might see in a Cathedral
customized algorithms are used to
compute every nook cranny and curve
we've seen it in the past in the pre
pre-modern days that architecture was
created with an incredible level of
detail if you look at baroque churches
if you look at the Rococo and so on but
it took an incredible amount of time it
took artisans years and years and years
to to create something like this the 3d
printer from Zurich needs two days to
build up the layers of fine sand a
binding agent is used to glue them
together and create the artificial stone
each decorative detail can be adapted
individually normally you'd have
problems with the scale and precision
but with this technique in terms of the
geometry there are no limits except for
the frame in which the printer works the
robots in the service of MX 3d and
Amsterdam on the other hand are free to
use whatever space they need which is a
lot it's one of the reasons the young
company is moving to a warehouse at the
edge of the city we start out with a
bridge small bridge first because we
have to develop and then later on we
will see where it leads us maybe new
bridges bigger bridges but also
constructions in the whole construction
world
use this technique we've built full
buildings maybe at a certain point and
there are no material restrictions for
the robots either the speed of
application is adjusted to enable the
lower layer to harden before the next is
applied we started testing with brass
with copper we're gonna do some tests
with aluminium for basically all metals
that you can actually well you can also
use for printing and it makes it really
interesting you can just switch the tool
and you have all new technique
construction of the bridge in Amsterdam
is set to begin in early 2017 after
planning permission and other conditions
have been met that gives the robots of M
X 3d plenty of time to practice
you